i hope you know it's pet week at 8 news
now every day we've got a lot of tips to
care for our furry friends our bialco
holmen she's made friends with some
cats and kittens over at the animal
foundation meow bianca
hey we're here at the animal foundation
i'm here with james we're calling him
jaime he's 11 weeks so he's an
older kitten but we were actually able
to we're going to let james go
okay he's going to explore where we were
actually able to head over to the kitten
nursery
the other day so before kids get big and
strong they're first in the nursery
the nursery is for the most vulnerable
animals where they are being
bottle-fed or weaned kittens require a
lot of care
they actually have to be kept warm
because they don't maintain their own
heat source
and up until they're four weeks they
have to be fed
almost every two hours so during that
four week period
we've learned that it's always good to
get the kids
acclimated and adjusted to people it's
an ideal time when they pick up many
habits like how to get your attention
right now is kitten season and a lot of
really good patrons find kittens in the
community
and the best thing to do is observe
those kittens from a distance
if they are healthy and mom is taking
care of them they'll let mom continue
and when they're ready to be adopted
bring them all in together so we can get
mom fixed
and of course to cat proof your home
black says to have many scratching posts
around the house because kittens like to
climb on furniture and chew on cords
and when children play with kittens or
cats be sure to give them a ball
or a toy that dangles so that the animal
doesn't scratch their hands so all great
tips
if you're interested in and getting a
cat or you have a cat and you're kind of
learning some new things to try
and so james is look he's enjoying this
little toy here
but there's so many different
opportunities to foster kittens
and to foster cats or even to adopt them
here at the animal foundation so
we'll of course have all that
information on our website reporting
bianca holman 8 news now